john i'm fairly certain that if one was
to walk into the cnn building in atlanta
they might have to show an id
right are you allowed to just walk into
cnn and pass the security guards
and press the button and go right up to
jeff zucker's office and open up his
door and sit down with him for a meeting
i don't think so so of course this is
all just silliness look this is the same
old nonsensical cry of racism
because that's really what this is all
whittled down to that the left does with
pretty much everything there is no
reason that you should not have to have
an id
to vote you need an id to get on a plane
you need an id
to buy a beer and john you know what you
need an id to rent a bike
because they want you to bring the bike
back okay but for some reason
we're telling people or they're telling
people that if you have
a requirement for an id to vote that
that is somehow racist that somehow
black people can't get an id
that in and of itself is deeply racist
what what person do you know that cannot
get an id and by the way
if you could show me a certain set of
people that are having trouble getting
an
id i'm not a big fan of using government
dollars for a lot of stuff because it's
really our money
but i would be okay with the government
then yes this is the thing i don't this
is give people some ideas this is the
thing i don't understand if ids are the
problem if
people not having ids with a problem why
do democrats not talk more about getting
these folks ids considering you need
them for almost everything
else to rent a movie or to rent a bike
as you say or to do anything you need an
id so if folks don't have access to an
id by all means let's help them
get id's the only other thing too i
think which anybody you know sometimes
this stuff gets really complicated dave
but what's really simple for everyone to
understand
is everyone said never again no more
holocaust no more genocide but we have
one
happening right now in china the biden
administration finally
using those terms genocide explicitly
and i'm sure
coca-cola and delta since they don't you
know they're not cool with any of this
stuff
they're going to pull their business out
of china i'm sure that's the next step
right
yeah it is april fool's day exactly
look of course this is silliness we know
that the nba which i think is the best
example of this from at a corporate
level
you know they bow to china because they
want the business in china and they'll
rail against the republicans in america
and what an evil racist patriarchal
state and they'll put
black lives matter on the court while
they watch their ratings tank
i think a third this past season after
dropping a third the season before
they'll they'll relentlessly
rail against america but saying anything
against their overlords in china
is something that they simply won't do
and and that really tells you a little
something about kind of how great
our capitalist democracy is and that you
can do that here and
right we are allowed to complain about
it right and we complain
sometimes we do it okay it's we don't
try to complain too much but
it's there's a time there's a time for
everything uh let's move on though and
talk about cancel culture and social
media
uh and you know every time i think it
can't get any more ridiculous it does
now facebook says they are censoring the
voice of donald trump on
all their platforms the social media
giant's new policy came to light when
trump's daughter-in-law lara trump
posted an interview with the former
president but they took it down and
here's their statement quote in line
with the block we placed on donald
trump's facebook and instagram accounts
further content posted in the voice of
donald trump
will be removed and result in additional
limitations
on the accounts he's the former
president
dave you don't like him that's fine but
what he says is important because he
could run again
and again oh i'm so so frustrated by
this
like i don't even know what to say what
do they mean by in the voice of donald
trump
whatever they want it to mean that's
what it means whatever they want it to
mean
whatever they want it to me that's the
point john it's whatever they want it to
mean i mean are they saying that going
forward if you
see donald trump outside mar-a-lago and
take a video of him saying hello they're
gonna ban you from facebook
are we allowed to post old videos of
donald trump are we allowed to post
the memes that were hot over the last
four years but look this is just an
extension of something that i talk to
you every week about
which is that big tech has a absolutely
ridiculous amount of control
over who can talk when they can talk how
they can talk who they can talk to
and the rest of it and until we start
scaling some of that power back and i
hate to tell you guys
it ain't gonna come from congress they
have these sham hearings every couple
weeks
and we all talk about it but they don't
do anything but until we stop
giving them our information you know i
was on sean spicer's show yesterday and
he said well it was lara trump's page
and i had to make the point of saying
well actually no
she thinks she owns that page but it's
facebook's page
it's facebook's page and until people
start owning their
stuff do not expect facebook
or youtube or twitter to do anything
that would be remotely close
to a free exchange of ideas that we
would care about if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell